the Supreme Court hears arguments today
in a case that could lead to the
deportation of nearly 700 thousand young
immigrants known as dreamers the
deferred action for childhood arrivals
program or daca protects undocumented
immigrants brought to the US as children
President Trump
ordered an end to daca two years ago but
lower courts blocked that move Jan
Crawford is at the Supreme Court Jan
what could happen here well Andy I mean
the question really here is whether or
not President Trump is going to be able
to end the daca program and say it's all
President Obama's fault because of the
way that President Obama went about
implementing it mr. Obama created the
daca program with the stroke of a pen
with an executive action without getting
any approval from Congress and President
Trump says whatever you feel about daca
that's illegal now President Trump has
sent some mixed messages on his feelings
about con the one hand he says we love
the dreamers but on the other hand there
are people in his party who take a hard
line on immigration states like Texas
were threatening to challenge it in
court now both sides agree that a
president Trump would just explain why
he didn't like daca he could rescind it
it's an executive action by his
predecessor if the Supreme Court though
strikes it down then that will put the
ball back in mr. Trump's president
Trump's court to work with Congress and
this morning President Trump tweeted
that if the supreme court overturns daca
a deal will be made with Democrats for
the dreamers to say that is a deal that
has eluded Congress though for most of
the past decade Gale all right Thank You
Jan